it's just a few hours till the grand
finale of the designers for tomorrow
prize for upcoming fashion stars in a
luxury hotel in Berlin event patron
Stella McCartney casts a look at the
finalists collections she and a jury had
narrowed the field of 350 applicants for
the best five contestants I have to say
it sounds really cheesy but I think
they've all really won because they've
really learned through this experience I
think and they've not only kind of
learned about you know what they may
need to do to enhance or develop their
collection I think they've learned a lot
about themselves it's pure coincidence
that all the finalists turn out to be
women the submissions were made
anonymously all that counts is talent I
think these the big girls seem to really
understand that they need to know
themselves and know their own hearts in
a sense to get their signature across
the final preparations began a few days
earlier the five finalists come from
Germany Britain and Romania they all
studied fashion and some of them are
showing their graduation projects here
they take the prize very seriously
because the designer for tomorrow award
offers the winner of the chance to
produce her first commercial collection
and to present it at Fashion Week
it skipped so feel annoyed there are so
many people who study fashion and try to
make a go of it and this is an
opportunity for people like me who don't
have such a money background to show
their things in Berlin so it's a
wonderful chance to be noticed as a
decision the reason charms only on my
Bagon ahmedabad european fashion
retailer piquant kloppenborg initiated
the prize in 2009 for the past two years
American designer Marc Jacobs has been
an advisor this year Stella McCartney
became the patron of the award many
young designers see her as a role model
the 41 year old is hugely influential
and she has certain principles she
follows to the letter she's a vegan and
her collections are entirely leather and
fur free increasingly as I get further
into my career I really see the need to
encourage and inspire and and support
the next generation of designers if I
can lend any kind of support and sort of
inside information that I'm really happy
to do so the award ceremony is one of
the highlights of Berlin Fashion Week
more than 700 guests streamed into the
tent at the Brandenburg Gate
guaranteeing the young designer is a lot
of attention
you're very nervous and you're very
excited they all seem very excited which
is nice it's not just all nerves so
that's good I think you're just a bit
overwhelmed you're not for me personally
I wasn't I don't think I was aware of
the magnitude of my first show at the
show each finalist presented several
complete looks all in just a few minutes
it's your lips
the winner this year's designer for
tomorrow is the Romanian you wanna chill
acha Marrone
she just really sort of had a great
point of view and a lovely silhouette
quite architectural quite statement but
at the same time quite wearable and I
think that's kind of what I'm looking
for in these kind of things somebody
that's really new in the way they
approach design but also at the same
time somebody that you you feel you want
to wear paradox is the title of the
collection submitted by the 31 year old
designer who currently lives in London
winning this award will give a big boost
to her career I'm not realizing it like
it's I'm out of my head and somewhere
else so yeah I think it's a great thing
because I remember thinking of the I'd
awareness past winners how lucky there
were so I guess I'm lucky but I cannot
feel it yet so it must seem a little
surreal to a jana chuda from Iran last
year she didn't even make it to the
final round and this year she is the
designer for tomorrow 2013